I'm Saoirse and I'm Mary and Mary Queen
of Scots I'm Margo and I play Queen
Elizabeth the first so we're gonna ask
each other some questions Margo quite
nervous actually
mm-hmm good if you weren't an actor what
would you love to do mmm it's funny
alpha because we were doing interviews
earlier for radio shows and I said that
exact thing that I would love to work in
the radio and whether it was behind the
scenes or whether I was a presenter at
Duncan good mind quite like to work on a
music radio station and just not have to
ever wear makeup ever again
I'm just not have any shoes on my caddy
right now what would you say well when I
was little I wanted to earn her tails /
be a magician
so if I could do buy some you take
nicely yeah I don't know if that's what
I want now I would want to be still in
the field
I'd need to be on film set in some
capacity I've missed that too much but
I'd love to work like pyrotechnics or
special effects
that'd be pretty rad what's one thing
your fans would be surprised to learn
about you my fans and do another name
for themselves better I think if someone
told me ages ago but they were called
this like assertion [ __ ] that's
something that an or are yours cult um I
once said an interview ah so I wouldn't
know I didn't know I had that and then I
saw online that a fan a very dedicated
one was like oh my gosh it's all that
fault she doesn't know that we have a
name like we're not doing a good enough
job and I'm so upset I was like no it's
just gonna have a look online yeah yeah
yeah
but now I know they are the robbers the
robbers and I so appreciate them and
they're very sweet and I hope they know
that was just my ignorance what was the
question I'm sorry what would what
something your fans would be interested
to learn about you I cannot juggle
juggle usually I can think of off the
top man I also think I'm a better dancer
than I actually am so use I don't know
if you're surprised I'm gonna be like no
we all
and all right king of the robbers queen
of the robbers if you could take one
personality trait of Mayan what would
you pick
oh this so Mickey you're very
quick-witted I would love to have that
you can might come back with something
so quickly and it's very like cool funny
at the same time Thanks I think if I've
got a good comeback I'm so excited about
it right guys right all right
we've both played a diverse range of
characters throughout our careers what
kind of role would you most like to play
next I have always wanted to be in a
silent film and it doesn't necessarily
have to be like an actual silent film
just film that doesn't have any dialogue
in us
I've always enjoyed doing stuff though
where I don't have to speak because then
you don't have to learn lines and I
would really like to play a boy because
I like the idea of figuring out what
that is and how that we would know yeah
so I'd quite like to say that splendid
what theme from Mary Queen of Scots was
the most challenging people probably the
first one the first one I ever did I
don't remember what it was but I'm
always terrified yeah once you do that
first scene there's no going back you've
committed to the mannerisms you've ended
it to accent you committed to their
voice everything and that scares me so
like the weeks leading up to playing a
role I get so stressed yeah once I've
done that first thing I'm like well I've
established it now now yeah it's about
nature
yeah is it a good one does that about
you because it's because we could talk
about oh great
was it well it was your reaction when
you found out we'd be working together I
was so excited it's Margeaux and I met
like better year-and-a-half before we
did the film together and I always
thought you were brilliant and like
fearless as an actor and every single
role you take on is completely different
and you can tell you just go for and
you're like all right lately you're
saying you're like well I'm in and I was
so I'm just gonna go for it well what
you know being able to share this with
someone who is not only really really
but RiRi you normally cure and you've
like surrounded yourself with your your
crew and your core friends and that's
amazing that you still have that even
though you're you know this is
successful you're welcome we're out of
time I'm referee time those [ __ ]
[Music]